Let's talk a little bit about
what I'll call the Plutsky
Plan, because it came from
my friend, Todd Plutsky.
But I think it's a good plan.
But let's think about a little
bit of its repercussions and
see if it's more or less likely
to actually work.
Well first of all, you know, I
threw out in the last video 50
banks, maybe that's logistically
difficult.
Instead of having 50 banks
with $14 billion initial
capital, maybe you do five banks
with $140 forty billion
initial capital.
But the point being is that you
should have more than one
bank, it shouldn't be too big to
fail, and you should try to
instill some type of
competition there.
But because they have pristine
balance sheets, all of these
banks are going to be able to
lever 10:1, which we know
isn't crazy.
Merrill Lynch and Morgan Stanley
and all the likes have
been leveraging up 30 to 40:1.
So 10:1 is normal for a bank.
And frankly, they're probably
going to be able to attract a
lot more-- you know we said
foreign governments probably
would be willing to lend to
them, the private sector is
willing to lend to them.
If these are commercial banks,
which means that they can take
deposits, a lot of people are
going to be willing to
essentially put their money with
this bank because it has
a clean balance sheet, and
essentially it'll be owned
individually by the American
people, and it will have the
federal backstop above and
beyond the FDIC insurance
limit and all that.
Although I do like the
one provision to
increase the FDIC caps.
Maybe I'll do the insurance
caps on deposits.
But it will actually be able
attract a lot of deposits from
everyday people.
They'll feel safer
with these banks.
So in terms of whether you'll
be able to capitalize these
banks and lever up 10:1,
I don't think
there's an issue there.
Then there's a question, will
it solve the fundamental
problem of keeping credit
markets flowing to those
people that it needs
to keep credit to?
Well we already said it'll have
no trouble being able to
have access to funds above and
beyond how much the government
capitalizes it with.
It'll be able to attract
deposits, it'll be able to
attract investment from the
private sector and from
international money, especially
with this five year
government backstop.
So it will be able to
essentially put 10 times this
money back into the system.
So if you take $700 billion
collectively, this will
introduce 10 times as much.
So $7 trillion of new loans.
So this $7 trillion -- I mean
that's literally half of the
American GDP.
I mean you might argue that is
too much -- that might provide
too much credit, and it might go
from, you know, thawing to
overheating credit markets.
So then you might say well if
$7 trillion is too much
liquidity, well why don't we
just reduce this number a
little bit.
Instead of saying $700 billion,
why don't you make it
a $100 billion, right?
Because then $100 billion, if
you do 10 banks with $10
billion each, so you introduce
$100 billion.
They all lever up because it's
all new liabilities and new
assets, clean balance sheets,
it'll introduce $1 trillion of
new loans that it can go put
to work for people building
factories and doing
real things.
And because their incentive is
not to bail out their friends,
it's not to help out the
companies they used to work
for, the companies that are
donating to them in some way
or contributing to them, or
promising jobs in some way.
It won't go -- this $1 trillion
is not going to go to
buy assets at higher prices
than they should.
You know it could go to buy
assets at discount prices if
the new managers of these banks
do see a good return.
But most probably they'll invest
it in areas of the
economy where they do see a
positive return on investment.
And one person had sent me a
note and said, hey, wouldn't
introducing all of this
liquidity into the financial
system, whether it's $7 trillion
or $1 trillion,
wouldn't that lead to
hyperinflation?
And I'll probably do a whole
series on inflation.
I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding around it.
In general, if anyone makes a
positive investment -- so if I
have $1 and I make it an
investment where it generates
$1.20 of benefit, that
by definition is not
inflationary.
Because I had $1 in the world
and I created $1.20 of wealth.
So actually, the pie
gets bigger.
A good way to think about
inflation -- I'll do a lot
about this because it is a
very abstract concept.
Let's say this is the
pie of goods and
services in the world.
Or let's just say
a country right?
Goods and services.
Goods and services in a year.
You could say it's our
GDP, or however you
want to measure it.
Goods and services
in a year, right?
That's the goods and
services in a year.
And let's say I have another
pool of the amount of money
there is in a given year.
So money.
And the money supply is an
interesting thing, because
it's not just dependent
on the amount of
physical coins or dollars.
It also is a function of how
quickly those transact and how
much leverage there
is in the system.
So you can actually have a whole
economy where everyone
just has one dollar bill, but
every time someone needs
something from someone
else, they exchange
that one dollar bill.
So that one dollar bill gets
used, you know, 15 trillion
times a year.
So you'd actually have $15
trillion of money, because the
velocity would be so high.
But anyway let's just say that
this is the pool of money.
If this pool, the pool of money
grows faster than the
actual goods and services and
the actual productive capacity
of that country, then
you have inflation.
So if this circle grows
faster than this
one you have inflation.
If this circle grows
faster than this
circle, you have deflation.
You have the same, or you have
some amount of money
representing more goods and
services, so goods and
services actually
become cheaper.
And the problem that we're
talking about right now, this
credit crisis, this is a problem
of deleveraging, where
the government injects a dollar
into this current
broken banking system, and
instead of that dollar -- you
know, the normal system is you
lend a dollar to a bank, so
you lend $1 to a bank,
and then, let's say
this is the Fed right?
This is how they inject
liquidity.
They lend a dollar to a bank.
Let me draw a bank here.
Then that bank has to keep -- it
can only lever 10:1-- so it
essentially has to keep in
reserve $0.10 of that dollar,
but then it lends $0.90 to
somebody else, to another
bank, right?
Then that other bank has to keep
10% of that, so it lends
$0.81 to someone else.
And then that someone else can
lend whatever $0.81 times 0.9
is, so I don't know,
seventy-something cents to
someone else.
But you get the idea, that in a
normal, functioning banking
system, one dollar injected
into the system has this
multiplier effect,
so it actually
creates a lot of money.
And that's what people are
implicitly talking about when
they talk about the
printing press.
But what's going on right now is
the Fed lends $1 to Bank A,
but Bank A is so scared that it
doesn't lend out to anyone
else, it just keeps
that dollar.
Because right now their main
priority isn't to try to get a
little bit of incremental
interest on whatever money
they have, their main priority
is survival.
So that dollar just goes
into a black hole.
And so that's what the
Fed's frustration is.
It keeps lending money into
the system but that money
keeps disappearing.
And actually as the economy
slows, the velocity of money
is going to slow down as well.
So the main problem when you
have a credit crisis and when
you have a recession
is actually the
money supply shrinks.
The amount of goods and services
probably shrinks as
well, but the money supply
shrinks even more.
So your main problem
is deflation.
And you know, that was the
main problem in the Great
Depression, and that was
the main problem in
the Japanese crisis.
And you know, Ben Bernanke, he's
written papers about this
and he's like, well you can
always cure deflation by
printing money and dropping
money from a helicopter.
Well to some degree that's
what they've already been
trying to do.
They've already been-- the Fed's
been willing to take
pretty large credit risks on
bank and lending money into
the system.
But the problem is, if this
multiplier effect is
disappearing at a faster rate
than you are dropping money
from a helicopter, you still
have deflation, right?
Before when you not only let
people lever 10:1, you let
them lever 30:1 and 40:1, every
dollar you put in the
system became $40 that was given
to someone else, and
then they could lever up.
So you had this huge
explosion of money.
And frankly, the only reason why
we didn't have inflation--
I mean the last 5, 10 years
we had this huge
explosion of money.
And the only reason why it
didn't, at least in measurable
inflation, show up, is that
on the other side of the
equation, you had all of this
new productive capacity come
on line in China and India.
And so manufactured goods
got a lot cheaper.
But in things that were not
manufactured goods, like
commodities, like homes, you had
this huge asset inflation.
Or even college tuition, or
healthcare-- things that are
dependent on American labor--
became hugely expensive, and
that's because you had this
huge, huge infusion-- you
know, there's different ways
to measure money, but the
broadest indicator, which is
called M3-- and I know I'm
kind of going out of the domain,
but I'll make a bunch
of videos on this.
The broadest indicator, M3,
which the government stopped
officially reporting, exploded
because there was so much
leverage in the system.
Now things are-- the exact
opposite is happening.
The leverage is disappearing
from the system.
There's no lending
to each other.
Everyone is going from 1:30
leverage to 1:10 leverage.
So money is actually
disappearing in the system.
The velocity is slowing.
This is shrinking, but this is
shrinking more, no matter what
the Fed is doing.
And frankly, this new $700
billion bail out, I personally
think this is the helicopter
that Ben Bernanke always
talked about using.
And whenever you're going to
drop money from a helicopter,
the question is, where
do you drop it?
And they think they should drop
it into an already broken
banking system.
The point of this video and the
last is maybe you should
just drop it into a new banking
system, or maybe you
just drop it into everyone's
pockets and see what happens.
And you let new banks
form where they can.
Anyway, that's all
for this video.
I know it was a little
bit rambling.
But hopefully you learned
a little bit.
See you in the next video.